think of
it makes me emotional
when i think of as a black woman
i must stand here today
before you
asking us to do something that the past
five presidents have done and four white
republican presidents
reauthorize the voting rights act so the
real question you should ask yourself
is what happened
what happened with this last president
that got us to where we are today
that my colleagues
will not stand up
and pass the voting rights act is it
because we win
is it because we vote
that is what you should ask yourself
let me end by saying that the president
made it very clear
where do you stand
do you stand with dr martin luther king
or george wallace
do you stand with
john lewis
or bill come
do you stand with abraham lincoln
or jefferson davis
we stand here
civil rights leaders
advocates
legislators
lawyers
we stand here
fighting for the people
and so today
i'm going to bring several members up
and we're going to do something a little
different we're going to do the floor
house
one minutes for
with the exception of our leader in
majority whip
flavor
and then i'm going to ask my members to
join me
birthday lady congresswoman sheila
jackson lit
will join me at the post
former chair of the cbc and good to have
our good friend flumat
back will join us to help address
questions with that
congressman
james clark
thank you very much madam chair i want
to surprise you with this
um
i don't think there is
any issue
more emotional
with members of congressional black
caucus
and
our constituents
than the issue of voting
i don't believe there's any
group of people
other than the congressional black
talkers in our constituents that are
really
practical
when it comes to the labor process
no group is any more practical than we
are
and that is why
when we sent
before the people act hr one
and the john r lewis
voting rights acts hr4
over to the senate
and we
saw
significant
reticence on the part of various
senators
and jill
senator joe manchin
of west virginia expressed support
for the thought of people like except
that he had
some misgivings about parts of it
so when he
decided
that he could put together
legislation
that he thought
would be bipartisan
and he proposed
what he called the freedom to vote act
every member of this caucus
and line up his supporter
demonstrating the practicality
of the political process
so the fall
the freedom to vote act
is not our bill
we
agreed to support
senator joe manchin's bill
so that's what this bill is
and we're finding
some real issues trying to figure out
why is it
that when we decided to support his bill
he seems
to be
supporting
a filibuster of his own vehicle
that to us
is very disconcerting
finally
i think that
all of us in the congressional black
caucus
are very understanding of our history
the 13th amendment three displayed the
14th amendment gave
us
rights of
due process
and
equal access
but it was the 15th amendment
it took
another amendment to the constitution
to give the newly slaves the right to
vote
that
amendment passed on a straight party
line vote yes yes
so we take exception grave exception
when anybody tells us
that legislation cannot have credibility
unless it is bipartisan
you're saying to us
that the 15th amendment is without
credibility
so we ask them all of our friends
inside and outside the congress to be
careful with that
that's not what history teaches us
and i'm pleased to yield
the chairman jeffers
thank you mr whip i thank you madam
chair for your leadership to all the
members of the congressional black
caucus the right to vote
is
precious the right to vote is sacred
the right to vote is central to the very
integrity
of our democracy
you can't have a government of the
people by the people
and for the people
unless every single american
has the unfettered ability
to choose their representatives
and fully participate
in american democracy
the voter suppression epidemic that has
been unleashed
by the radical right
is unacceptable unreasonable
unfathomable unconscionable and
unamerican
we must crush it
and we will crush it
that is why
it's essential it's important
it's necessary
with the fierce urgency of now
to pass
the joe manchin freedom to vote act
and the john robert lewis voting rights
advancement act
by any means necessary
including reforming a filibuster rule
that is dripping in racist history
in defense of slavery
and jim crow
on this issue make no mistake
when it comes to the protection
of the voting rights of every single
american we shall overcome
last week we marked one year since
insurrectionists stormed the u.s capitol
to overturn a democratic election
in the weeks before the attack
some republicans made despicable false
claims against voters in my state of
nevada but they failed
their insurrection failed
and in the years since nevada has made
protecting voting rights our sacred
mission
today the congressional black caucus is
here to use our power and our message
to call on our senate colleagues to
protect the freedom to vote
seize
this moment
pass the john r lewis voting rights
advancement act
pass
the joe manchin freedom to vote act
guarantee safe secure and free elections
for all americans the world is watching
us and now is the time to stand up for
our democracy
hi i'm congresswoman terry sewell and i
proudly represent alabama's 7th
congressional district which includes
the historic civil rights cities of
birmingham selma and montgomery
it was in my hometown of selma 56 years
ago where john lewis and the foot
soldiers shed blood on a bridge for the
equal right of all americans to vote
but as we know all battles have become
new again as state legislators across
this country erect
deliberate barriers to the ballot box
trying to silence a certain group of
people
these news laws may not require us to
count how many jelly beans are in a jar
but modern day voter suppression is no
less pernicious
yesterday i was honored to join
president biden and vice president
harris and our madam
leader of the congressional black caucus
joyce baby
as the president spoke of an urgent need
to protect the sacred right to vote i
applaud the president for being
unequivocal
in his statement that by any means
necessary we must
change the rules of the senate and pass
the john robert lewis voting rights act
our nation is at an inflection point
voting right legislation will go to the
senate floor and it must pass
you know we're on the anniversary the
cusp of
the martin luther king celebration day
monday
but there can be no celebration
without liberation
without freedom
without the right to vote
as we prepare to observe the birthday of
reverend dr martin luther king let us
remember that just as delayed can be
just as denied
the time to act is now nothing is more
fundamental to our democracy than the
sacred right to vote
the time to talk is over
it's now time to act
my name is colin allred
represent texas's 32nd district i'm
proud to be here
my colleagues in the congressional black
caucus but i'm also a former voting
rights lawyer
i can tell you
we knew
when we'd go into court there'd be some
judges that we weren't going to get a
good ruling from
we knew that
the courts might not be on our side
we always had
the law
we have the voting rights act
we don't have that protection right now
and we know that it's not going to be
the courts that are going to protect our
rights
right now
it's going to have to be us in the
congress
and so the congressional black caucus is
coming together today
to say to the united states senate
there is nothing more important
after our capital was attacked by people
trying to overthrow our democracy
after a rash of laws have passed across
this country to try and make it harder
for certain americans to vote
in the state of texas where it was
already the hardest state in the country
to vote they just went and made it
harder
that now is the time to act
that believe us
believe us when we tell you i've spoken
to voters who've been disenfranchised i
can see the light go out of their eyes
the belief in our democracy leave them
we have to restore our democracy and
this is the time
we cannot let a senate rule
a senate rule that is based and was used
almost exclusively to prevent civil
rights
prevent us from rising to this moment i
know all of us in the congressional
black caucus will do everything we can
but we're calling on the united states
senate
we're calling on a few senators in
particular
to rise to this moment
pass your own bill senator
pass the john lewis voting rights
advancement act give us the tools to
rescue our democracy and let us let the
chips fall where they may in the next
elections
thank you
val demings representing florida's
10th congressional district we are the
home of the brave land of the free
the greatest nation
in the world
but we are here today to hold america
to its promise
i stand today remembering my parents
my father was a janitor and my mother
a
maid my dad used to go to work seven
days a week to make ends meet
for our family but i cannot remember a
time
that my parents
did not pass
their vote they saw it as their
civic
duty
my parents understood that their vote
while they didn't have enough a lot of
money their name was on no buildings
their name wasn't famous people didn't
rise when they walked into the room that
their vote mattered
and it mattered just as much as the
richest man
or woman in town we can talk about
health care we can talk about civil
rights we can talk about women's rights
we can talk about social security
medicare education
but all of it is at risk
all of it
everything that you care about
regardless of your party and everything
that we care about is at risk if we do
not protect the right to vote
we're not going anywhere
we're dang on sure not going back
we will use every
tool every tool within our power
to protect
the precious
sacred
right to vote
good afternoon joe nagoos representing
the great state of colorado and as
representative sewell
reminds us in just a few days tens of
millions of americans will commemorate
martin luther king jr birthday
and of all of the insightful
things that martin luther king imparted
us with
here in his time as earth there's one
quote that's always resonated with me
and i suspect
some of my colleagues which is that the
time
is always right
to do what is right
the time to safeguard voting rights to
protect voting rights and to advance
voting rights is now not next year
not next month not next week
here and now and in the face of over 400
laws that have been introduced in the
last year to restrict voting rights in
florida and in texas in iowa and in
georgia
all across the country we know the
stakes couldn't be higher
so to our colleagues in the senate we
simply say
that the eyes of the world are on you
the world is watching the country is
watching and the congressional black
caucus is watching
we hope
you will do the right thing
good afternoon i'm mondaire jones
representing new york's 17th
congressional district
our democracy is in crisis
the insurrection at the capitol
on january 6th of 2021 told us so
and now the same party that incited that
violent attempted overthrow of the
federal government
because of the deep unpopularity of its
policies
is seeking to disenfranchise large
swaths of the american electorate
chief among them black and brown voters
there is a way to stop that from
happening
we must pass
joe manchin's freedom to vote act
and the john r lewis voting rights
advancement act
we are faced with an existential
question
about whether we will have
representative government
for we the people
moving into this upcoming year
and the answer
can be yes
but only if we use the limited time we
have available to us only if we use
the power
that the american people have given to
us to secure the fundamental right to
vote
we know that voting rights are
preservative of all other rights
and nothing comes close to being as
important certainly not
a filibuster of accidental origin
that has been weaponized to block the
same kinds
of civil rights legislation
that we are simply trying to enact into
law today this is legislation that
was
previously non-controversial in the
early 2000s i remember marching with the
naacp in washington dc as a young
activist
to reauthorize the original voting
rights act which was done unanimously in
the senate when does that ever happen
and nearly unanimously
in this chamber
and so we have got to do the right thing
and we have got to prevail upon with the
help of the president of the united
states who has endorsed filibuster
reform
senators mansion and cinema to rise to
this occasion and to make an exception
for the purpose of saving our ailing
democracy
thank you
hello
i'm congresswoman lisa blunt rochester
i represent the state of delaware
i'm the last of the one minutes
and
it's really hard
it is unbelievable
that we are standing here
today
the congressional black caucus
is here to say
the time is now
i was fortunate yesterday to travel
with the georgia delegation so many
members of the congressional black
caucus
terry sewell
and our chairwoman joyce beatty
who has exhibited incredible leadership
and has shown the country that the cbc
all of us will stand up and fight
even go to jail
for voting rights
i was honored to hear our president and
our vice president the first woman
the first african-american and
asian-american
speak
about the urgency of now
but as unequivocally talk about january
how they did with january 6 talk about
how high the stakes are
and i think everybody here pretty much
summed it up
it is about access people having access
to the ballot which martin luther king
talked about give us the ballot
it's about suppression
and trying to stop people
from getting water
on a on a voting line
when they're just trying to exercise
that right and it's about subversion
stealing elections
we are the conscience of the congress
the congressional black caucus
and many of you have seen i carried this
scarf on day one
i carried it the day of the insurrection
i carried it to atlanta
it is from georgia
it was the oath that allowed my ancestor
to have the right to vote
it took
brave people
to stand up and vote to end slavery the
reality is had there not been courage
before
we would not be standing here
and so today
we say to the members of the senate
to pass the john robert lewis voting
rights advancement act
to pass the freedom to vote act
to know that this is not just about a
policy
this is about our entire democracy
our way of life
i'm proud to be a member of the
congressional black caucus
and i'm proud to say
this
is our power
and this is our message to the senate
thank you thank you
thank you to uh all of my colleagues we
will take a few questions but let me
just say
thank you to my colleague
it's always the right time
to do what's right
the fierce urgency of now
and one last one
from martin luther king
doesn't matter where you stand in the
time
of comfort and convenience
but it is the actions
that you take
during a time
of challenges
and controversy
it is the time now senate
to take that action
elected officials
don't hide
don't not support voting rights and then
dare
to celebrate
king's birthday
stand with us we'll take questions as i
ask you a jacksonville and can we see
who made to join me at the vote
are there any questions
and we'll ask you to monitor the
questions for you madam chair thank you
just as a caucus as a whole
what are you doing have you had any
direct conversations with senators
mansion or cinema are you doing anything
as a caucus to put additional pressure
on them and then secondly obviously
president biden will be here tomorrow
do you think that can change hearts and
minds beyond his speech earlier this
weekend if these
bills fail again
what is the plan b
well first of all let me say yes yes and
yes uh yes that uh on behalf of the
congressional black caucus and you've
heard our majority whip say he has met
with mansion and talk with those
senators
i have talked with met with a cinema
colleague of mine uh when i came in as a
freshman to congress and a friend
so we've had a number of conversations
i've had a conversation with senator
manchin uh too many to count with
senator schumer and let me just say the
congressional black caucus
brought senator schumer into our
official caucus meeting where we've had
a dialogue he was most gracious
yesterday
in taking time from his meetings to talk
with me multiple uh times so we are
conversing they know where we stand and
we've seen progress
you know we brought him into the caucus
and we started talking about it had to
happen now before the king's breakfast
we wanted to see action
within 48 hours
he was talking to the media using by
january the 17th or the king's
birthday and i take great pleasure in
saying that happens because of us
we've not been signed
so to your questions we met with the
president the vice president as
congresswoman lisa rochester said
we flew out on the plane with them and i
assure you going
and coming back
one conversation
voting rights
being more engaged
and taking the debate making the debate
and taking the vote
thank you thank you
now i'll go to you thank you do you wish
then the senate you mentioned your
conversation with senator schumer do you
wish the senate moved sooner on this
like they spent a lot of time on the
buildback federal agenda was this
something that should have been taken up
last fall when this first when this
first got started with uh john lewis
right voting rights still was first
introduced
well clearly
you know we want voting rights uh we
can't look back to what didn't happen
before uh certainly when you work hard
the house has done their job we voted on
it we
uh passed it uh in the house we would
have liked that continuing to have taken
place it didn't so here we are now uh
wanting the voting rights you want to
add anything to them
[Music]
as well let me just combine the two
questions that have been asked
um and i think you need to take a clear
look at us
we love our fellow members but you're
looking at black faces
you're looking at faces that are the
direct target of the lack
of voting protection
i stand here i believe is the first
member who lost her district
in redistricting that was pointedly
attempting to eliminate two black
members who happen to be members of the
congressional rock office
i am not imagining i am speaking
so here's what i think in terms of both
your questions
there is no doubt that we have lived and
breathed
and constantly been involved
in discussing
from the very minute that terry sue
introduces bill and before
i was here for the reauthorization and
back in the 2000s
helped write it and it was everybody
together
you have to ask the question
why when the size of the numbers of
votes in 2020 were so large
and so full of color
that you had the big lie and the
insurrection
and so i don't want this to be looking
this way at the congressional black
caucus
or do we wish that they had done it
earlier
there are two obstacles members in the
senate who are willing publicly to say
that they're opposed that have to be
democrats
and then the new dixiecrats the
republicans
who have race
as a blinder
that they can't see so i simply want
you to say and i think the answer is
we are here now today
let us have the courage of our
convictions today
i sent this five-page letter to senator
manchin i've given him enough time
to respond i will make it public now
and it only suggests if he could have
the courage
of west virginia
that succeeded from virginia because
they did not want to support slavery
so just simply end by
we have done everything we could
we are very grateful to the president
vice president grateful to majority
leader schumer and to our chair
but i want it to be looked out the
question needs to be asked of those who
are stopping the vote in the senate
can you
understand dr king's words that i will
close with
and he said we shall overcome
the ark of the moral universe is law
but it bends toward justice
if we get that done if he thinks that
way
if he's courageous
all of this will be for naught to get
rid of the filibuster thanks we'll go
there
there and there and then we'll probably
have to close after that
thank you
there's going to be reporting about uh
potentially using a nasa bill as a shell
to move it back to the senate
um speed it up avoid sense or procedural
hurdles
but inevitably it still seems like it's
heading towards the filibuster in the
senate do you have any reaction to some
of this new legislative maneuvering is
it a procedure is it sufficient
i don't know that it's new certainly if
you look back to history
we have done all kinds of things we do
what we want to do certainly there has
always been a
an opportunity in our process that you
can bring a process to procedure vote to
the floor you can also have a deal in
the house and put a bill in it and send
it back then
uh to the senate which you're making
reference to the nasa bill uh we've done
that throughout our history for us we're
very clear we want to vote and we want
to send it to the president
and that's so
however
it can happen i think mr clyburn said
the history out well uh when we're not
going to hold ourselves to whether it's
bipartisan or the process
i don't want to be flippant i want a
bill i want it passed it is the senate's
process for however they get it done we
want it signed by the president next
what do you say to your constituents and
voting rights advocates who are growing
concerned if either bill isn't passed as
we approach the 2022 midterm elections
i feel sorry
for those on the other side
who didn't support
this
you know we're very clear our
constituents understand
where we are
our constituents understand at all
levels
they understand victory they saw a black
president elected because they voted and
they stood in line for five to seven
hours to vote
you have heard the president himself say
thank you majority whip clyburn thank
you south carolina
thank you black people
for voting overwhelmingly to elect him
that then got us our first female black
asian american vice president our people
know that
our people understand that
who should be afraid or those who won't
stand up for voting rights so we're
sending a clarion call and you can print
this
shame on you for not doing it black
folks will vote no matter what
so it's not what's going to happen to us
it's what's going to happen to them
okay yeah um if the filibuster is uh
removed then both of these bills do end
up able to pass would you be concerned
then without a filibuster if a future
republican congress could come in and
potentially implement voting laws like
the ones in georgia and iowa that were
referenced earlier in this press
conference except this time they could
be on a national level and there'd be no
filibuster to stop it
well let me just say if you expected me
to count on what my racist colleagues
and folks on the other side have been
doing it doesn't matter whether there's
a filibuster or not they're going to do
what they're going to do look at january
the 6th and what happened look at some
of the laws that they're putting in
place so for us it's the urgency of now
for us
is getting the voting rights
law passed signed by the president and
i'll worry about two years when i get to
two years boys
um i want to thank
our chair
our caucus leader our whip all the
members of this distinguished caucus
that are with me and around me
to just underscore and perhaps
put in historical context
why this means so much
to all of us
34 years ago
in
this building
a young
john lewis
stood with me
as we
went to a press conference unknowing
what we were going to deal with
and one of the questions that came up
was well what is the priority
of the congressional black caucus
and john and i because we had a way of
just linking arms stood at the podium
and almost in unison said it is the
right to vote and to have every vote
counted and the protection of those
rights
he never wavered
never ever waited
and so when there was an opportunity for
me
to leave the congress and to give up
what a lot of people think are the
trappings of power
john and his late wife lillian and i sat
down together and said you know
you really are going to have to accept
this offer from the naacp
you're going to have to leave the
congress
and you're going to have to go out into
the hinterland and do on the outside
what both of us and so many others have
been trying
to do
on the inside
and so i left
to head up the naacp for almost 10 years
and to work in every state
in this nation
on the notion of a very basic concept
that he held up to his death that was
near
and dear to his life the right of people
to cast an unfettered ballot
with every expectation that that would
be
counted
and so it was irony for me to come back
after being away for 24 years
and to see john in the state he was in
when i got back
and he called and he said well my friend
you've come back in
from the cold
but the fight
that fight that we talked about in 1987
is still very much alive
so
when the chairwoman talks about the
visceral meaning of this to all of us or
the gentlewoman from delaware or anyone
else it is not contrived it is what we
believe it is what we feel it is in our
dna
and is what we are compassionately
committed to
no matter what
trust me john lewis is in this room now
his spirit
30 40 years later still resonates
in this building
and the tragedy the tragedy
is that we are now fighting the same
fight
that many of us thought
was behind us
the senate of the united states
will be forced and i hate to even say
that but they're being forced
to take a vote on this
it's convenient if the vote never comes
up but it will come up
and everyone will be judged
by history on how they stood
on how they acted
on how they voted
when the rights of americans all across
this country to vote and to have those
votes counted
would in fact come before them i urge
everyone
in the senate
to think about the things that have
preceded you and all of us to think
about this nation to think about the
history of segregation and jim crow the
history of exclusion so that when you
cast that vote in the senate you are
casting it to do away with those things
not to reaffirm them thank you madam
chair thank you
our power our message this ends our
press conference thank you thank you all
for coming to all the members thank you